[Music]
kate middleton is taking over prince
harry's duties as the royal patron of
the rugby football league and england
rugby and turns out she's good
really good what kate's doing is putting
her own stunt onto that title which she
will one day inherit and i think now we
are seeing the seeds that have been sewn
we are seeing the work that she's put 10
years into now coming to fruition and
it's work that really is making a
difference to celebrate her new role the
duchess of cambridge participated in a
fun video where she tosses the ball to a
few rugby players
and if all that wasn't impressive enough
at one point the mom of three spins the
ball on her finger in a statement kate
said that she is thrilled to be working
with the two organizations who are
committed to harnessing the power that
sport can have in bringing communities
together and helping individuals
flourish the royal adds that she is
looking forward to working with them
across all levels of the game and
cheering england on in what promises to
be an exciting year for both sports
and kate she's jumping into the roll
feet first joining in an england rugby
training session in london on wednesday
the duchess practiced some drills and
was even lifted into the air to catch a
ball as the players cheer her on
kate's always been a very confident very
self-assured young woman indeed when
someone once remarked her that she was
lucky to be going out with william she
said well he's lucky to be going out
with me and i think that says a lot
about her confidence she now has a
decade of royal experience under her
belt but even back at st andrews where
of course this love story started she
knew where she wanted to go in life and
the woman that she wanted to be the
principles that she had then are the
principles that she stands by today
friends and family have always been
incredibly important to her and she's
always had a great sense of faith in
herself
the patronage was previously handled by
kate's brother-in-law prince harry who
officially relinquished his
responsibilities last year when he
stepped down as a senior member of the
royal family the departure of the
sussexes did leave a big hole not just
in royal family but almost on the public
stage and
you know i think many people thought
that with harry and megan leaving that
would be the end of the fun and the
glamour and you know everything that
people love about the royal family
and in fact it hasn't been and it's been
largely down to kate people respect her
they look up to her they admire her
she's very much seen as a role model
aside from kate's new role 2022 is
shaping up to be a milestone year for
the duchess who celebrated her 40th
birthday in january
she is now 40 she is a very confident
poised self-assured woman and with a
great sense of humor a lot of talent it
seems that kate's more willing to let
her guard down a bit and show us a bit
more of the real kate
[Applause]
[Music]
you